t
[Música]
[Aplausos]
e
generar en 1950 el matemático inglés
alan turing se preguntaba pueden pensar
las computadoras por la misma época los
llamados cibernéticos así a una pregunta
análoga pero ligeramente diferente se
preguntaban si el cerebro humano puede
ser visto como una computadora si en
algún sentido es una computadora
ambas preguntas tienen sentido pero
también tiene sentido ubicarse en la
posición del informático holandés
tarjeta extra quien decía que la
pregunta acerca de si las computadoras
pueden pensar le parecía tan poco
interesante como la pregunta acerca de
si dust y los submarinos pueden nadar
con esto de extra refería que pensar a
las computadoras como demasiado humanas
en una pérdida si decía que las
computadoras no tienen por qué parecerse
a las mentes humanas de hecho no no
tengo deberían porque tenían por qué
imitar a las mentes humanas podrían
invitar mejores cosas bashir dax de
alguna manera las computadoras tienen
actividades cognitivas por métodos
diferentes y segunda extra mejor es que
la mente humana
no olvidemos que los algoritmos los
programas los robots son uno de los
mejores logros de la humanidad y de
alguna forma extienden nuestra
capacidades cognitivas
ahora bien está extendida de entidades
cognitivas mejores que la mente humana
no es 37 inquietud incluso no se habla
como alguna gente habla de una amenaza
existencial como si éstas estas máquinas
pudieran reemplazar o amenazan con
reemplazar a los seres humanos o incluso
exterminarlos
de hecho recordemos que en el año 1997
en particular el 29 de agosto la
computadora bélica skynet tomó
conciencia de sí misma y esa consciencia
la llevó a percibir a la humanidad como
una amenaza y decidió exterminar lo
una de sus armas más efectivas para ello
fueron unos robots humanoides llamados
terminator
si sabemos una ficciones en una ficción
que revela una preocupación recurrente
en la cultura humana
ahora bien las computadoras pueden tomar
conciencia de sí y esa conciencia las
revelará emociones deseos o prejuicios
humanos
la verdad que las computadoras pueden
tomar conciencia de si lo vamos a ver
pero esa consciencia no tiene por qué
parecerse a la consciencia humana
de hecho la consciencia humana es algo
bastante
difuso bastante labio y bastante poco
definido
pensamos que nuestros procesos mentales
nuestro cuerpo siempre lo percibimos
placer percepciones limitadas por
ejemplo pelo papá me gusta pelar papas
me gusta cocinar y muchas veces me pelo
un dedo he pelado papas por décadas
conozco cómo hacerlo conozco mi cuerpo y
conozco el instrumento sin embargo me
distraigo mi percepción es limitada si
yo simplemente pienso en otra cosa y me
pele un dedo por supuesto que un
terminator no es en el pasado lo mismo
si es que pelar papas claro
o nos enamoramos la gente se enamora
no ha pasado no sé cómo joven enamorado
recorrer caminando en transporte público
barrios desconocidos de la periferia a
altas horas de la noche visto desde hoy
obviamente mi percepción de mí mismo en
ese entorno y del entorno en sí era por
lo menos deficiente
los robots se enamoran también se podrá
enamorar
la literatura y el cine han mostrado una
cantidad de casos de personas que se
enamoran de robots
es amor será correspondido
y esos robots como actuarían enamorados
o quizá mejor que eso quizá los podrían
establecerse vínculos afectivos lazos
amorosos entre distintas especies
lazos que de alguna manera trasciendan
el mero enamoramiento biológico
esa es una de las mensajes que nos deja
el director ridley scott en su película
blade runner
ahora bien volvamos al tema de las
mentes
las mentes humanas o no pero sobre todo
las humanas siempre estuvieron
extendidas no están dentro del cráneo
siempre se constituyeron gracias
andamiajes externos si impulsamos
herramientas más recientemente la
historia humana cuadernos por ejemplo
lápiz y papel donde escribimos el
lenguaje alfabético lenguajes numéricos
usamos fórmulas matemáticas para
calcular cuestiones del mundo o
diagramas para representarlo y por qué
no especialmente en el presente programa
de computadoras todo eso forma parte de
esas mentes que constituimos
ejemplo de esto si yo le dijera ahora
multiplica en dos números de diez cifras
casi nadie en el mundo puede hacer eso
si lo hacemos mentalmente entendiendo la
mente interna nada más pero si usa el
lápiz y papel recordamos las tablas y el
método para calcular cualquier persona
lo puedo hacer con bastante
confiabilidad ese proceso es el proceso
de computación está distribuido entre la
mente interna el lápiz el papel el
sistema perceptivo este a motor de hecho
el mismo alan turing se inspiró en ese
procedimiento para definir en 1936 una
idea de computación que da lugar después
a las computadoras modernas
esta u otra otra nación actual que
cotidiana tenemos que recordar una
cantidad de actividades por ejemplo
venir hoy acá a filmar una cantidad de
cosas que uno hace cada día no nos hace
falta acordarnos de todas nos alcanza
con recordar donde guardamos la agenda
lo mejor que es últimamente podemos
recordar cómo abrir el calendario la
computadora incluso en ese calendar van
a aparecer una cantidad de citas o de
actividades que ni siquiera nosotras
mismas escribimos que están ahí porque
alguien las puso
tenemos que entender que esta evolución
de las de los andamiajes externos los
algoritmos en este caso permite eliminar
parte de la memoria humana y permite una
mejor evolución de las mentes poder
pensar el vínculo entre humanos y
programas humanos sistemas técnicos que
ya están en todo el ambiente por este
camino nos ayuda realmente a entender el
mundo actual por supuesto que muchos de
esos vínculos entre humanos algoritmos
no son tan buenos y uno de ellos el más
común que tenemos el que el cotidiano es
con las redes sociales los motores de
búsqueda los algoritmos de recomendación
en general esos algoritmos nos permiten
ver el mundo de una manera particular
que no podríamos sin ellos pero a la vez
también introduce en sus propios sesgos
o sus propias vidas parciales y también
el vínculo que tenemos no suele ser
virtuoso porque esos algoritmos intentan
están diseñados para capturar nuestra
atención y para mantenernos atrapados en
sus redes
pero por supuesto que hay otras
plataformas que tienen otro tipo de
vínculos más colectivos más creativos
quizás menos conocidas hoy igual me voy
a concentrar en un vínculo particular
virtuoso creo yo entre a algoritmos o
sistemas robóticos y personas las
operaciones de ojos también a la vista
originalmente o nuestros inicios esas
operaciones las realizaban la
oftalmóloga con un láser en su mano
donde podía hacer las incisiones para
reemplazar un cristalino o corregir una
miopía sin embargo se iba desarrollando
cada vez más sistemas
mixtos sistemas de integración entre la
oftalmóloga y un robot que tiene un
sistema perceptivo mucho más preciso y
puede realizar mucho mejor las
incisiones correspondientes ese ese
robot es esa inteligencia artificial
tiene por supuesto conciencia de sí si
no la tuviera no nos someteremos a la
operación es decir conoce sus partes que
no son humanas no son un brazo sino
partes específicas o no se puede ver y
percibir el ojo del paciente conocen los
tiempos sus propios procedimientos y el
tiempo externo para poder sincronizar
los
quizá incluso podría pelar papas mejor
que yo eso sin duda siempre si
aprendiera
nos preguntamos hace un rato pueden
enamorarse los robots quizá otro tipo de
robots y esperemos que estos no
para
que quería reflexionar en esto también
el lugar de los humanos en el mundo en
este momento
por un lado descubrimos que la
biodiversidad es condición necesaria
para la preservación de la vida en la
tierra y que la humanidad como especie
es sólo una parte de una biosfera
múltiple y rica y que es adiós feira es
condición de su existencia pero también
sabemos que los humanos vivimos en un
mundo técnico en un medio técnico y que
también es necesario entonces una
tecnología
formas de integración y de acoplamiento
virtuosos entre humanos y objetos
técnicos en un digamos en un paisaje de
inteligencias diferentes un paisaje
cambiante aparte
quiero dejar para terminar una frase que
de alguna manera sintetiza una de las
cosas que dije hasta ahora una frase que
también podríamos leer a la luz de lo
que la corriente feminista ha iluminado
que el hombre masculino blanco en
general no es un paradigma de la
racionalidad humana que solo una forma
más de inteligencia que es contingente e
históricamente condicionada
podemos hoy entonces invertir la
formulación que hizo el sofista griego
protágoras hace ya 25 siglos y afirmar
que hoy ya el hombre no es la medida de
todas las cosas